en el último vídeo definimos la energía
interna literalmente como la energía de
todo el sistema y eso es digamos una
versión todo incluido verdad digamos que
tengo aquí mi sistema en algún tipo de
contenedor y un montón de partículas ahí
dentro literalmente es la suma de la
energía cinética de todas esas
partículas y tuvieran energía potencial
también lo metemos potencial eléctrico
lo metemos si tuvieran enlaces entre
cada una de estas partículas y la
energía de cada enlace también lo
metemos es todo incluido y bueno como
les dije es poco intuitivo porque usamos
la uv para energía interna pero bueno
pueden pensarlo como el universo de toda
la energía del sistema no solo para
memorizarlo no se claven mucho en eso
pero bueno esta es la energía interna
energía interna y si me muestran un
sistema tiene cierta energía interna ok
es una función de su estado no no me
importa cómo llegué a ese estado pero si
me dices a lo mejor que un sistema está
en cierto estado digamos que es con
cierta presión cierto volumen o cierta
temperatura
yo te puedo decir cuál es la energía
interna especialmente si tú me dices el
tipo de molécula que tengo ahora también
dijimos en el último vídeo que debido a
que la energía interna es energía del
sistema no puede crearse ni destruirse
solo se puede transformar de una forma a
otra ok entonces si tengo un cambio en
la energía interna
si tengo un cambio en la energía interna
solo puede deberse a bueno puede deberse
a un buen de cosas pero para nuestro
mundo sencillo que vamos a describir
ahorita que digamos tratar con gases que
es normalmente lo que uno ve en un
primer año de química esto va a ser por
el calor agregado al sistema más el
trabajo hecho en el sistema hacia el
sistema y como dije en el último vídeo a
veces podemos cambiarle el signo del
trabajo cuando el sistema realiza cierto
trabajo y ahí pierde energía pero bueno
solo quiero hacer una discusión aparte
de esto porque he decidido escribirlo de
esta forma sin las deltas del lado
derecho y la razón es porque si
escribimos esta ecuación que de hecho
verán en muchos libros de texto sus
maestros se los van a dar
sí sí yo lo hago así al menos me
clarifica las ideas de lo que el calor y
el trabajo están haciendo respecto a la
energía interna si escribiera yo del
tabú iguala al ala delta delta del cubo
es decir del calor más delta w esto
implica que hay en cierto punto tuve y
tuve cierta cantidad de calor en el
sistema y después tuve una cantidad
distinta de calor y tomé la diferencia
entre esos dos estados verdad tuve un
cambio en el calor eso implica que el
calor es de alguna forma un un macro
estado inherente del sistema y ese no es
el caso
ok si vemos por ejemplo este sistema les
puedo decir cuál es la energía interna
de este sistema y les puedo decir su
presión su volumen su temperatura
estas son macro esto son macro estados
del sistema no sé cómo llegué a esta
situación pero te puedo decir de ello
estas variables no te puedo decir cuál
es el calor del sistema y eso puede ser
un poco poco intuitivo porque sí
si yo te pregunto bueno cuál es cuál es
el calor de una taza de café bueno tú me
dirás su temperatura porque usamos las
dos palabras sin distinción pero en
termodinámica el calor es una
transferencia de energía una forma de
pensarlo es si la energía interna es
digamos una una cuenta bancaria
digamos que pensemos en el cambio en la
cuenta la cuenta bancaria cuenta
bancaria y en realidad es como una una
cuenta bancaria de energía del sistema
si tenemos un cambio en tu cual en tu
cuenta bancaria puede deberse a
depósitos o retiros verdad y el calor y
el trabajo son como depósitos y retiros
en el sistema entonces el el calor pues
de algún tipo digamos una transferencia
bancaria digamos que el calor sea como
una transferencia bancaria
más los depósitos los depósitos de
cheque
los depósitos de cheque
ahora hace mucho sentido digamos cuál es
mi valor de mi cuenta bancaria o podrías
decir cuál es el cambio en el valor de
mi cuenta bancaria
ok tomamos dos tiempos distintos y
entonces tiene sentido decir que por
ejemplo deposite diez dólares en
transferencia bancaria
ok entonces le agregamos diez dólares y
puedo decir que escribir veinte dólares
de cheques entonces le restamos veinte
dólares en cuyo caso me cambio en la
cuenta bancaria de menos diez dólares
ahora lo que tiene sentido para mí es es
cuál es el cambio en la transferencia
bancaria es decir no no no cobra mucho
sentido digamos inicialmente tenía 100
entonces ahora tengo 90 entonces cuando
hice una transferencia bancaria
la transferencia bancaria no cambia es
decir esto es un valor que yo tomé que
fue un cambio de un punto a otro pero es
no no puedes decir que hay una
diferencia en una transferencia hay una
no hay un cambio en las transferencias
bancarias verdad aquí por ejemplo en los
depósitos del cheque tampoco verdad
entonces si yo hice 10 una transferencia
bancaria de 10 dólares y deposite 20
dólares en cheques al final tuve un
cambio en mi cuenta de 10 dólares ok
entonces esencialmente el calor y el
trabajo funcionan de la misma forma ok
entonces el calor puede pensarse como
una una una si introducimos o retiramos
cantidad de energía de nuestra cuenta de
energía pero bueno no podemos decir en
si cuánto calor tiene un sistema eso es
algo que no está dentro del no es una
variable no es una variable del sistema
tiene esa energía interna lo más cercano
al calor y que veremos en un vídeo
futuro dental pía que esencialmente es
una forma de medir cuánto calor está en
él
pero no vamos a hablar de eso ahora no
podemos decir cuánto trabajo hay en un
sistema no podemos decir ah el sistema
tiene x de trabajo si no el sistema hace
o recibe trabajo que es por eso la
energía del sistema puede usar como
trabajo calor en fin como muchas cosas
pero no podemos decir cuánta voz de esto
hay ok no son variables o funciones de
estado con esto dicho y con esto que sea
nuestra definición de energía interna
quiero que hagamos algunos problemas
para que se sientan cómodos con esta
expresión y mi objetivo va a ser saber
cómo usar el más o el menos cuando
hablamos de trabajo ok entonces vamos a
pensar qué es lo que está ocurriendo más
que memorizar la fórmula entonces
digamos que tengo un globo digamos que
no tuviera yo ningún cambio en la
energía interna es decir que nuestro
cambio en la energía interna es cero y
para fines de este ejercicio voy a
pensar que las partículas digamos todo
todo el cambio se debe a una expansión
en el globo
ok voy a hacer un poquito más voy a
trabajar en esto de expansión en el
siguiente vídeo pero digamos que el
sistema se hace a 10
jules de trabajo por expanderse 10 jules
de trabajo mi pregunta es cuánto calor
tuve que agregar o tomar del sistema
cuánto calor tuve que agregar o quitar
entonces la forma en que puedo pensarlo
es digamos si escribimos la fórmula
puedes decir me da la energía interna la
energía interna del sistema no ha
cambiado y el sistema hizo 10 dulce
trabajo es decir eso es energía que sale
del sistema son 10 jules de energía que
salen en forma de trabajo si la energía
interna no cambió entonces esencialmente
estos 10 hits de energía tuvieron que
haber entrado también al sistema 10
jules tuvieron que haber entrado para
que no cambie la energía interna verdad
es decir para compensar los 10 goles que
salieron entonces 10 goles tuvieron que
entrar es la es la única forma en que la
energía interna se mantenga igual verdad
entonces tienen que entrar como calor 10
jules como calor sale fueron agregados
al sistema de esta forma y vamos a ver
esto desde el punto de vista de la
fórmula si teníamos delta o igual al
calor agregado
déjenme ponerlo con este color calor
agregado más el trabajo hecho por el
sistema entonces tendríamos ok si esto
era igual a cero entonces el calor
agregado al sistema recordemos en este
en este ejercicio el trabajo hecho por
él es éste por el sistema fue hecho por
el sistema es decir sacó energía a
través de calor verdad entonces en sí en
este caso el trabajo fue hecho por el
sistema y de hecho lo hizo de 10
entonces se le restan porque pierde
energía y entonces resolvemos en la
ecuación para q y tenemos que 10 es
igual a q verdad sumando 10 de ambos
lados de la igualdad pero bueno esto
puede ser un poco confuso a veces pero
bueno simplemente decimos si el calor
fue agregado al sistema de esta forma o
tomado entonces es que podemos
determinar los signos del calor verdad
el calor fue agregado en este caso el
sistema
tenía 10 positivo de calor verdad
entonces fue agregado el calor si el
sistema tiene trabajo hecho es decir el
sistema de hace trabajo entonces tiene
signo negativo si hacemos un trabajo
sobre el sistema entonces es positivo
ahora del tabú es igual a q - el trabajo
aquí es cuando el trabajo está hecho por
el sistema ok en este caso es el que
teníamos verdad otra vez esto es igual a
0 y 0 es igual a q que es el calor
agregado al sistema menos el trabajo
hecho el trabajo hecho por el sistema
como les dije al inicio del problema era
de 10 jules verdad 10 jules de trabajo
entonces tenemos menos 10 llull si
tenemos la misma expresión que teníamos
sacar arriba verdad y eso nos deja que
10 es igual aquí de cualquier forma el
calor agregado al sistema es de 10
juntos vamos a hacer uno más digamos que
no sé qué que 5 jules 5 jules de calor
fueron de calor aunque ya fueron
quitados del sistema no sé a lo mejor se
enfrío qué sé yo pero con tomados del
sistema y digamos que un joule de
trabajo
tenemos un joule de trabajo hecho sobre
el sistema quizás porque estamos
comprimiendo el globo o qué sé yo
entonces cuál es nuestro cambio en la
energía interna ok entonces vamos a
figurar nos cuál es el cambio así que sí
sí yo quité 5 jules de calor desde es
decir tengo menos 5 verdad quite 5 jules
y luego tengo un joule de trabajo hecho
en el sistema sobre el sistema entonces
tengo menos 5 y le sumó 1 verdad que
entonces tengo menos 4 entonces tuvimos
un cambio en la energía interna de menos
4 verdad esto es igual a el calor
agregado o tomado del sistema más el
trabajo hecho por o hecho sobre el
sistema en este caso tenemos que el
calor fue tomado entonces tiene signo
negativo y es de 5 más el trabajo hecho
sobre el sistema es decir aplicamos un
trabajo en el sistema de un joule
entonces le agregamos energía y nos da
menos 4 ahora podría haber escrito esta
misma fórmula como del tau el cambio en
la energía interna es igual al calor
agregado al sistema menos el trabajo que
hace pero en cualquiera de estos dos
casos éste es pero no te confundas
realmente hay que tener muy claro qué es
lo que estamos diciendo con estas
fórmulas más que memorizar las verdad en
este caso él
el calor es menos 5 y menos el trabajo
que el sistema hace esto es cuánto
cuánto hace cuánto hace trabajo el
sistema bueno el sistema tiene un joule
de trabajo hecho sobre de él entonces
hizo un trabajo negativo verdad
entonces es menos -1 y quiero ser claro
cuando usamos esta fórmula este es el
trabajo hecho por el sistema
esto es hecho el trabajo hecho hacia el
sistema entonces el sistema tenía
trabajo hecho sobre el sistema quiere
decir que tiene un signo negativo verdad
entonces hagan lo que sea intuitivo para
ustedes para mí es más fácil pensar en
esta fórmula simplemente estoy
ejerciendo un trabajo si lo estoy
haciendo para el sistema entonces el
signo es positivo verdad igual si el
calor lo estoy agregando el signo es
positivo nos vemos en el próximo